light forces need high quality
communications to coordinate
decentralized efforts into a coherent
whole okay so this this article was
written 40 50 years ago
something like that and
it's just interesting to me
communications of all kinds are
unreliable
radios they're all unreliable in a
combat zone
and if you don't have coordination
measures
in effect that don't rely on radio
communications
you can count on there to be problems
and i'll tell you even as our
as our as our communication capabilities
get better
when you start talking about fighting
against near-peer adversaries
meaning big giant countries like ours
that have big giant technological
uh equipment like we have
you can't you get to a point where you
can't use radios because they have
something called dfing capability have
you ever heard of that direction finding
capability
so if you key up your radio they know
where you are
your radio gives off radio waves and
there are ways
that radi those radio waves can be
detected
and they can pinpoint your location so
so you have to be able to operate
with minimal minimal communications
so i don't like the this this particular
one because it says light forces
need high quality communications to
coordinate decentralized efforts into a
coherent hole actually i don't i don't
like that
when i tell you this is what we're doing
this is why we're doing it i give you
the commander's intent
i want you to be able to go and i don't
need to talk to you again and by the way
you'll see whatever other unit needed to
do something coordinated with you you're
going to know what's happening by what's
happening
you're going to see an explosion you're
like oh late splatoon just started their
breach that means i can go like you you
see what i'm saying
you need to be able to coordinate things
you can't be reliant on radios
you can't there's probably a year
there's probably a
five five year time period
where you where the radios were good and
the enemy
direction finding capability wasn't
quite there yet
but that period's over
due to a general shortage of combat
support light forces must do an
excellent job of combining arms when
they have a chance yes absolutely you
got to be able to work with the other
units that can support you
you got to be able to light infantry
forces must be masters of improvisation
familiar with all kinds of weapons
vehicles landing craft and so forth
yes light infantry forces make use of
whatever is at hand to improve their
combat capability
absolutely
native irregular forces are often used
in support of light infantry
yes what does that mean that means you
have to go build relationships with the
local populace that's what that means
in order to do that you gotta know that
that's what you need to do
because 18 year old kids with machine
guns
aren't focused on building relationships
they're not
they go into a country they have a
machine gun they have grenades
and if that what they think they're
going to do is hawk grenades
and shoot machine guns so you need to
educate them and make sure that they
understand
how the local populace is going to play
a role
in giving you support
light infantry must remain flexible in
mind and action capable of reacting
quick
quickly already talked about flexible
plans flexible mind
when a light infantryman rises from his
sleep he is ready to fight
i like that light infrastructure men
rely on camouflage why is that because
we don't want to give away our position
we don't want to advertise what we're
doing we don't want to advertise how
we're beating the competition
we want to have camouflage against heavy
enemy forces
the light infantry always requires a
great deal of
augmentation cool you've gotta you gotta
face the reality
that you may not have the resources that
are needed
to defeat a bigger stronger enemy
you have to be able to say that so if
you're you know that's why that's why
there's a lot of
industries right now where you can get
help
inside your small business you can get
it support
you can get personnel support you can
get engineering support you can get all
this kind of support
and you've got to recognize when you
need to utilize some of that other
support
you might not necessarily want to build
it out i had this conversation life was
just telling me this
when we were starting ef online
and you know we started talking about
building this and building that and i
said hey leif
we don't want to become a software
company and he was like
check you know because it's better to
hire someone that does that that's what
they do for i don't want to i don't want
to have a bunch of
software engineers and programmers and
i.t so i don't want to
we don't want to have all that yeah
that's a different business yeah really
we don't want to be an eye
we don't want to be a software company
we want to be a leadership training
company
cool and he was he was like got it yeah
because we had started because
it's one of those mission creep things
right where you're like you're like well
if we just add this we just build that
and all of a sudden
you got a proprietary system that you
got to maintain
and hire more people we're not looking
to do that we why we think light
infantry
and what you need to do is use
augmentation if needed
light infantry men must be able to climb
crawl swim ski snowshoe repel
stalk run and hide
obviously echo this was written before
snowboarding yes because i know you're
over there thinking
for those of you that don't know echo's
now a snowboarder
isn't it interesting to actually talk
about the fact that you got to have all
these different
ways of getting around by using your own
energy light infantry must be
able marksman proficient in the use and
maintenance of many weapons light forces
rely on
pioneer skills at all level beginning
with the squad
to properly exploit terrain pioneer
skills
does that mean you have a ralph's card
no but you better know where everything
is that's what i'm saying otherwise you
get lost these foreign stores
you know you can be hostile do you
remember driving around yeah you do
remember no g like gps is just so
yeah it's a given it's given now yeah
together
how did you get around before gps do you
remember off the top of your head
like you're in a new spot or you're
going to a new spot kind of far away
you brought a map no you get a map yeah
well i guess if i was going somewhere
where there wasn't going to be a way to
live off the land and go into a
convenience store
and buy a map i was taking my daughter
to coronado like a little while ago
and so coronado is where i worked for 20
whatever years
yeah and what i live now
a few miles from coronado and we get in
the car
and i you know start pulling out my
daughter's like do you want to put in
the gps yeah
you're all insulted i'm like are you
serious i
i said are you serious right now and she
says yeah why and i go
it's coronado i worked there for 20
freaking years
yeah and she's like well i didn't i
don't know
but that's but that's her mentality is
when you get in a car and you're going
somewhere your gps oh yeah huh because
she's just
the only way it is yeah huh yeah that's
crazy oh but well because i had the
exact same incident wasn't coronado it
was downtown
and i used to work downtown for a number
of years and go down there whatever
so i know downtown i know downtown like
back of my hand yeah
and we're going in same thing she puts
it in sarah sir yeah puts it in the
or is like she puts it in her gps in her
phone and starts
rattling off the directions as if i
don't know
you know look at this man of the world
doesn't know
um you know how to get to the place
we're going to downtown
my hood yeah whatever um so yeah i don't
need that gps but
the thing is sarah's not as young as
your daughter obviously but
it does start to become like a habit you
know i mean just so happened i
knew my way around i think if i didn't
know my way around see that same thing
the automatic
style like i don't even think twice
about it like in
back in the day i used to go um you know
to places or whatever and i remember
going in the either the white pages or
the yellow pages or whatever they'd have
the map
in the front of it and then i'd write
down directions
that's it i got lost before two couple
times but it's not not quite as
effective as yeah
i wonder what's how much that skill is
just being lost now
i'm sure it feels like it's gone
straight up gone
you can find one or two guys and and we
could be real negative about that
or we could also be well what skills
have people now
garnered because they don't have to
worry about that skill anymore yeah
i'm not sure the next one the pertinent
ranger standards of land navigation
are a must for light forces
gotta know where you're going gotta know
where you are yeah
light infantry rarely uses roads or
trails what does that mean
how does that apply i'll tell you it
applies you find new ways of doing
things
and just because there's a beaten path
doesn't mean you should necessarily take
it doesn't mean you can't take it
but you should think is there a better
way to get this done
light infantry forces left in combat
theaters for long
inevitably become heavier due to the
acquisition of heavier weapons plus
increased logistics structure what does
that mean keep moving
keep moving the minute you settle down
now you're going to start to now you're
going to start to grow in ways that
aren't necessarily beneficial
light infantry appreciates heavy fire
support when it is available but is not
dependent on it
physical conditioning and mental
strength are absolute musts
across the board